el problema dice si las ecuaciones
siguientes definen la misma función
polinomiales fx es decir que a b c y d
representan la misma función
f x solamente que por ejemplo aquí
tenemos un binomio al cuadrado perfecto
y aquí otro de ellos aquí tenemos una
expansión en cuadráticas aquí tengo una
expresión cuadrática y aquí tenemos otra
expresión cuadrática aquí tengo a efe x
factor' izada como la multiplicación de
uno dos tres cuatro binomios ok esta
factorización es muy buena para
encontrar raíces y aquí tengo a fx visto
como una función polinomio de cuarto
grado ahora si te das cuenta si
expandimos esta o multiplicamos esta o
multiplicamos toda esta vamos a llegar a
la misma función pueden lineal de cuarto
grado después nos preguntan qué forma de
fx es más útil para determinar el
comportamiento en los extremos y bueno
cuando nosotros queremos saber el
comportamiento de los extremos lo que es
importante es fijarnos en él
mayor de toda la función polinomiales en
este caso el término mayor ya se nota
que es x4 este es mi término mayor así
que hay que fijarnos en este término
mayor porque si queremos saber cómo se
comporta en los extremos recuerda que
cuando x es muy pero muy pero muy
negativa este término predomina ante
todos los demás y cuando x es muy pero
muy pero muy grande positiva este
término va a predominar también a
comparación de los demás ahora si te das
cuenta el inciso de nos sirve bastante
para darnos cuenta que ésta es una
función poniéndome al de 4º grado porque
ya está de una manera explícita además
si te das cuenta aquí tenemos que el
grado máximo de esta función poligonal
es 4 y entonces podemos decir que como
el máximo exponente de esta función es
un número par entonces esta función se
va a comportar en los extremos como una
equis cuadrada ahora hay que tener
cuidado porque no solamente se va a
comportar como una equis cuadrada habría
que fijarnos en el coeficiente que está
al lado y en este caso es menos 2 y con
menos 2 es un valor negativo
entonces podemos decir sin temor a
equivocarnos que esta función polinomio
de cuarto grado su comportamiento de los
extremos va a ser muy parecido a equis
cuadrada pero negativa porque tenemos
una potencia par y además tenemos un
coeficiente negativo por lo tanto se va
a parecer mucho a menos x cuadrada y
todo eso lo podemos ver gracias a que
tenemos aquí a la función polinomio ya
vista como una función polinomio de
cuarto grado donde nos dan
explícitamente cada uno de sus términos
muy bien por lo tanto esta es la forma
más fácil de poder ver a esta función
posicional para encontrar el
comportamiento de los extremos por lo
tanto vamos a ponerle aquí que es el
inciso de ok
seleccionada de entre las ecuaciones
siguientes ya que tenga un
comportamiento los extremos semejante a
efe x y bueno justo eso acabamos de
responder como en esta función tiene
como grado un grado para es decir el
exponente mayor de la x es un número par
y además al lado tenemos un coeficiente
negativo entonces se va a aparecer a
menos x cuadrada en los extremos del ojo
justo lo que habíamos dicho
vamos a ver qué me dice acá abajo porque
acá abajo también tengo otra pregunta
qué forma de fx es más útil para
encontrar ceros y si nos fijamos en
todas estas que tenemos aquí arriba
podemos decir de una manera muy fácil
que es justo el inciso set el inciso c
es muy fácil para encontrar los ceros de
esta función porque si igualamos esto a
cero entonces ya tenemos que o éste debe
ser cero o éste debe ser cero o éste
debe ser cero o éste debe de ser cero
cada uno de estos binomios debería de
ser cero para encontrar las raíces de
esta función y entonces cuando igualamos
cada uno de estos a cero es muy fácil
encontrar así cuáles son los ceros de
esta función por lo tanto el inciso c es
la forma en que más nos ayuda a
encontrar los ceros así que vamos a
subir comprobar respuesta correcto
estamos bien